you created sci-pi over two decades ago
now yes right yes i'd love to talk about
sci-fi sci-fi was really my baby
what is it
uh what was its goal what is its goal
how does it work yeah fantastic so scipy
was effectively here i'm using python to
do
stuff that i previously used matlab to
use and i was using numeric which is an
array library that made a lot of it
possible but there's things that were
missing like i didn't have an ordinary
differential equation solver i could
just call right i didn't have
integration hey i wanted to integrate
this function okay well i don't have
just a function i can call to do that
these are things i remember being
critical things that i was missing
optimization i just want to pass a
function to an optimizer and have it
tell me what the optimum value is
uh those are things like well why don't
we just write a library that adds these
tools
and i started a post on the main list
and they're previously been you know
people have discussed i remember conrad
henson saying wouldn't it be great if we
had this optimizer library or david ash
would say this stuff and and i'm you
know i'm a
ambitious uh and this is the wrong word
and eager
and
uh
probably more time than sense i was you
know poor graduate student
uh my wife thinks i'm working on my phd
and i am but part of a phd that i loved
was the fact that it's exploratory
you're not just you know
taking orders fulfilling a list of
things to do you're trying to figure out
what to do and so i thought well you
know i'm writing tools for my own use
and a phd so
i'll just start this project and so in
99 98 was when i first started to write
libraries for python especially when i
fell in love with python 98 i thought
well there's just a few things missing
like oh i need a reader to read dicom
files that was in medical imaging.com
was a format that i want to be able to
load that into python okay how do i
write a reader for that so i wrote
something called
it was an i o package right and that was
my very first extension module which is
c so i wrote c code to extend python so
that the pos in python i could write
things more easily that that combination
kind of hooked me it was the idea that i
could here's this powerful tool i can
use as a scripting language in a high
level language to think about but that i
can extend easily
easily in this in c that easily for me
because i knew enough c
and then guido had written a length i
mean the only the hard part of extending
python was something called the way
memory management networks and you have
to reference counting and so there's
there's a tracking of reference count
you have to do manually and if you don't
you have you have memory leaks and uh so
that's hard plus then c you know it's
just much more you have to put more
effort into it it's not just i have to
now think about pointers and have to
think about stuff that
is different i have to kind of you're
like putting a new cartridge in your
brain like you're okay i'm thinking
about mri now i'm thinking about
programming and there are distinct
modules you end up having to think about
so it's harder when i was just in python
i could just think about mri and high
level writing um but i could do that and
that kind of i liked it i found that to
be enjoyable and fun and so i ended up
oh well let me just add a bunch of stuff
to python to do integration
well and the cool thing is is that you
know the power of the internet i just
looking around and i found oh there's
this net live which has hundreds of
4chan routines that people are written
in the 60s and the 70s and the 80s in
fortran 77 fortunately it wasn't for
trends 16. so they've been imported to
fortren 77
and 1477 is actually a really great
language
fortunate 90 probably is my favorite
4chan
because it's also it's got complex
numbers got a raise and it's pretty high
level now the problem with it is you'd
never want to write a program in fortune
90 or fortune 77 but it's totally fine
to write a subroutine in
right and so and then 4chan kind of got
a little off course when they tried to
compete with c plus plus but at the time
i just want libraries to do something
like oh here's an order different
equation here's integration here's run
cut integration
already done i don't have to think about
that algorithm and you could but it's
nice to have somebody who's already done
one and tested it and so i sort of
started this journey in 98 really looked
back at the mailing list there's sort of
this this productive era of me
writing an extension module to connect
wrench cut integration to python
and making an ordinary digital equation
solver and then
releasing that as a package so we could
call od pack i think i called it then
quad pack and i just made these packages
eventually that became multi-pack
because they're originally modular you
can install them separately but a
massive problem in python was actually
just getting your stuff installed
at the time releasing software for me
like today it's people think what does
that mean well then it meant
some poorly written web page i had some
bad web page up and it put a tarball
just a gzip tar ball of source code that
was the release
but okay can we just stand that because
that the community aspect of creating
the package and sharing that yes
that's rare
that to have to both have
at that time so like it was pretty early
yeah so well not not rare maybe maybe
you can uh correct me on this but it
seems like in the scientific community
so many people you were basically
solving the problems you needed to solve
to process the particular application uh
the data that you need and
to also have the mind that i'm going to
make this usable for others
that's um i would say i was inspired i'd
been inspired by linux i've been
inspired by you know linus linus and him
making his code available and i was
starting to use linux the time and i
went this is cool so i'd kind of been
previously primed that way and generally
i was i was into science because i liked
the sharing notion i like the idea of
hey let's if collectively we build
knowledge and share it we can all be
better off okay so you weren't energized
by that so it's energizability already
yeah right and i can't deny that i was
i'm sort of had this very
i liked that part of science that part
of sharing and then all of a sudden oh
wait here's something and here's
something i could do
and then i slowly over years learned how
to share better so that you could
actually engage more people faster one
of the key things was actually giving
people a binary they could install
right so that wasn't just your source
code good luck
compile this and then it's compiled
ready to install you just you know so in
fact a lot of the journey from 98 even
through 2012 when i started anaconda was
about that like it's why uh you know
it's really the key as to why
a scientist with dreams of doing mri
research ended up starting a software
company that installs
the software i work with
a few folks now that don't program
like on the creative side the video side
the audio side and because my whole life
is running on scripts i have to try to
get them i'm have now the task of
teaching them how to do python enough
yeah to run the scripts and so i've been
actually facing this whether it's on the
condor some
with the task of how do i minimally
explain basically to my mom how to write
a python script
and it's an interesting challenge it's a
to-do item for me to figure out like
what is the minimal amount of
information i have to teach what are the
tools you use that one you enjoy it to
your effect of it and they're related to
related questions and and then the
debugging like the the iterative process
of running the script to figure out what
the error is maybe even for some people
to do the fix yourself yeah so do you
compile it do you destroy like how do
you distribute that code to them and
it's interesting because i think
it's exactly what you're talking about
if you increase the circle
of empathy that the circle of people
that are able to use your programs
you increase it its like effectiveness
and its power and so yeah you have to
think
you know can i write scripts can i write
programs that can be used by biomedical
engineers by all kinds of
people that don't know programming and
actually maybe plan to see
have them catch the bug of programming
so that they start on their journey
that's a huge responsibility and
ultimately has to do with the amazon
one-click buy
like how how frictionless can you make
the early steps frictionless is actually
really key to growing any community is
every any friction point you're just
going to lose you're going to lose some
people yeah right now sometimes you may
want to
intentionally do that if you're early
enough on you need
a lot of help you need people who have
the skills you might actually it's
helpful you don't necessarily have too
much too many users as opposed to
contributors if the co if you're early
on
anyway there's uh uh sci-fi started in
98 but it really emerged as this
collection of modules that i was just
putting on the net people were
downloading and they you know no i don't
know i think i got 100 users right by
the end of that year but there but the
fact that i got 100 users and more than
that people started to email me with
fixes
like and that was actually intoxicating
right that was the
that was the you know here i'm writing
papers and i'm giving conferences and i
get people would say hello but yeah good
job but mostly it was you're reviewed
with
it it's competitive yeah right you
published a paper and people were like
oh it wasn't my paper you know
i was starting to see that sense of
academic
life where it was so much i thought
there was a cooperative effort but it
sounds like we're here just to
one-up each other right and
you know it's not it's not true across
the board but a lot of that's there but
here in this world i was
getting responses from people all over
the world
uh you know i remember pierre peterson
in estonia right was one of the first
people and he sent me back this make
file because the first thing is yeah
your build thing stinks and here's a
better make file now it is a complex
make i don't think i never understood
that makefile actually but it worked and
it did a lot more and so then thanks
this is cool and that was my first kind
of engagement with community
development but you know the process was
he sent me a patch file i had to upload
a new tar ball and i just found i really
loved that and the style back then was
here's a main list it was very it wasn't
as it certainly were the tools that are
available today it was very early on but
i really started that's the whole year i
i think i did about seven packages that
year right and then by the end of the
year i collected them into a thing
called multi-pack so 99 there was this
thing called multi-pack and that's when
a high school student knows a high
school student at the time guy named
robert kern
took
that package and made a windows
installer
right and then of course a massive
increase of usage so by the way most of
this development was under linux yes yes
it was on linux i was a linux developer
doing it on munix box i mean at the time
i was actually getting into i had a new
hard drive did some kernel programming
to to make the hard drive work i mean
not programming but modification to the
kernel so i could actually hard drive
working
i i love that aspect of it i was also in
you know at school i was building a
cluster i took mac computers like uh and
you put yellow dog linux on them
they were at the mayo clinic they were
just all these macs that were older they
were just getting rid of and so i kind
of got permission to go grab them
together i put about 24 of them together
in a cluster and a cabinet
and put yellow dog linux on them all and
i wrote a c plus
program to do mri simulation that was
what i was doing
at the same time for my day job so to
speak so i was loving the whole process
at the same time i was oh i need a
ordinary differential equation that's
why ordinary difference equations were
key was because that's the heart of a
block equation for simulated mri is a
ode solver and so that's
um but i actually did that it doesn't
happen at the same time that's why it
kind of what you're working on and what
you're interested in they're coinciding
i was definitely scratching my own itch
in terms of building stuff
and uh which helped in the sense that i
was using it for me so at least had one
user yeah i had one person who's like
well i know this is better i like this
interface better and i had the
experience of matlab to guide some of
what those apis might look like but you
know you're just doing yourself you're
building all this stuff but with the
windows installer it was the first time
i realized oh yeah the binary installer
really helps people
and so
that led to spending more time on that
side of things so around 2000 so i
graduated my phd in 2000 end of year
2000. so
99 doing a lot of work there 98 doing a
lot of work there 99 kind of spending
more time my phd you know helping people
use the tools thinking about what i want
to go from here there was a company
there's a guy actually eric jones and
travis vott they were
two friends who founded a company called
nthot it's here in austin still here
and they
eric contacted me at the time when i was
a
i was a graduate student still and he
said hey why don't you come down we want
to build a company
you know we want we're thinking of you
know a scientific
company and we want to take what you're
doing and kind of add it to some stuff
that he'd done he'd written some tools
and then pierre peterson had done ftp
let's come together and build pull this
all together and call it sci-pi
so that's the origin of the scipy brand
it came from you know multi-pack and a
whole bunch of modules i'd written plus
a few things from some other folks and
then pulled together in a single
installer
sci-fi was really a distribution of
python mastering as a library
you